I'm right here
's meal
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Rosalia she's a
two-time Grammy award-winning artist and
producer coming off an incredible year
that included a 15 country World Tour in
the release of moto mommy the album with
the highest Metacritic rating of all of
2022. an exciting news she has new music
out as well her EP with Raul Alejandro
is called RR and it's available now
Rosalia welcome to the show thank you so
much how are you around spicy food
before we get started I'm not familiar
with it yeah this is not something that
I have at home
so I'm not really familiarized with it
to be honest well today you'll get a
full crash course are you ready to get
started
[Music]
oh my God oh my God okay classic hot
sauce
see what it's all about
[Music]
isn't this nice mhm
it's not spicy
[Music]
it's more Maple than chili
after a pair of more serious albums I
know that you're excited to Unleash Your
playfulness and sense of humor from Moto
mommy how did your approach to making an
album change once you decided to unlock
that side of yourself
I really think that that's my I don't
know my main goal in life is just to be
as free as possible so I think that the
music is a reflection of who you are so
if you if you're free then the music is
free and so I was like
yeah let me try to just have fun when I
do this this project not the mommy and
I'm a huge fan of the album I've been
able to stop listening to it for like a
week and excuse the pronunciation but
like your song Sogo right that's all yep
and it has this like little jazz piano
thing yeah how do you think about
blending the Contemporary with the
traditional in your art the tradition is
just it's just a foundation
in order to create in order to do
something you have to know what it's
been done so I think that yeah the
classics are something that I I learned
to love because the Masters I I had I
had different Masters I still have
Masters and that's what Classics are for
I think to look back to know where you
come from to know where you're going
thank you
okay
[Music]
I like it there we go two for two yeah
you're a hot sauce person all along no
yeah all along you think so I think so
because the two first ones let's see the
others
let's see it's not bad there you go
who cooked this they did good yeah yeah
the wings are kicking today yeah you did
good yeah thank you good Dom thank you
so much
it's a little bit more spicy now yeah
right right when you start talking a
little bit sometimes it kind of unlocks
it there
it's more spicy after it they build a
little bit yeah
hooray I sound like a lot of breakout
Stars you actually have a decade of
formal music training studying at
academies like the Catalonia College of
Music which helped to inform your first
album yeah we asked lizzo this question
but I'm curious your perspective how did
studying classic music theory how did it
affect the way that you approach making
hits now
in theory it just allowed me to whatever
I had in my head I was able to to
material I was able to write it I was
able to okay let me read this how
somebody else again the classics how
somebody else thought of writing a song
and then it allowed me understand better
the the possibilities in in
using chords it allow me so many things
understanding where the Melodies
intervals the options
it's just knowledge I remember somebody
said knowledge sometimes it may not
allow you to be so creative like maybe
it makes your creativity be less
expansive but I is I think it's the
opposite
I think it's slow Puesto I think the
more knowledge you have the
the more freedom you're gonna have I
think
[Music]
lemon I like lemon
it's gentle there we go I'm trying to
just keep up with you
[Music]
it's fine there we go you like all three
of them it seems like so far yeah there
we go there we go I thought it was going
to be much worse
well you know we got we got we got a
ways to go we got a ways to go I'm gonna
be honest with you all right all right
so understand that during your years of
training you'd work as an autonomous
singer for hire doing wedding gigs or
doing performances at restaurants yeah
where you're paid all kinds of [__] A
little over 80 Euros or in exchange for
dinner yes did you have a favorite local
Tableau to perform at
I definitely loved one but it was the
most special because it was
the only one I think maybe that was a
bar where some jazz people would play
too
but also Flamenco would be like
traditional like like
amazing traditional Flamenco and that
was called Jessie Jessie and Barcelona
yeah yeah I remember that that man he
would be like this is the Flamenco
Cathedral I used to feel nervous before
going on stage but I remember that that
built me
if I was performing in a restaurant it
would be a challenge because they didn't
go to see you perform right they go
there to eat so it's a challenge and
I'll be very like I'll be like no no no
no
they're gonna they're gonna hear they're
gonna hear me tonight yeah they're gonna
listen to what I'm doing they're gonna
be like no no I don't care about the
food let me hear this you know so that
would be also something that would
taught me so much because really it's
really tough I really respect people who
do that people who perform in clubs who
perform in restaurants who perform in
weddings who perform in parties like
it's just it's hard it's a challenge and
you have to be very very strong
psychologically I think
[Music]
I like chocolate
yeah coming through a little bit this is
spicy yeah this one I knew yeah
[Music]
um
yeah do you like it though at all no no
not at all not at all is disturbing yeah
like a spicy Disturbed like
it's disturbing uncomfortable
uncomfortable the ball's closing in here
in this interview there we go there we
go it's happening the hot ones
experience this is it
hmm
do you have a favorite classic art
reference from one of your music videos
you know from Frida Kahlo to Botticelli
to Francisco Goya you know you see these
masterpieces of the past echoed
throughout your work I let go of the
ones you said you do I love Classics
yeah I I love it
his movies are really amazing I love
Pedro I love
um Monet is amazing and his paintings
relax me every time I see a Monet
painting I think it's my favorite
paintings can be inspiring to write a
song
um movies can be inspiring to write a
song I think anything can be an excuse I
don't know if these are is inspiring to
write a song but but it might Shake
something loose my shake something yeah
[Music]
it's probably my in my lips
going forward you know with every new
Wing there will be a new thing okay you
know you like like my throat is itching
a little my lips are numb you know my
tongue feels like ice in my mouth you
know all those different things noise
uh but you're doing great see you're
doing great you're doing fine okay I
thought it was worse I think chocolate
when I like better the taste of it but
it it was more hot yeah it left behind
like a little bit of a trail right
exactly exactly
your albums have incredible drum
production on them oh thank you what are
super aggressive drums and then why were
they important for you when you were
conceptualizing Moto Mommy
I love that you asked that no I think
that drums gives a lot of energy
and I wanted that Moto Mommy
would be like a roller coaster there was
a clear intention and then I was like
drums can give me the aggressive
aggressiveness that's how you call it
right aggressiveness yeah the
aggressiveness that I wanted to achieve
I could get it with drums in orchestra
music literally when they use the drums
it makes it just more violent more
aggressive personally I really love this
type of drums Como drums
yeah well speaking of drums
right here
this next one okay
is a spicy shark
cardamomo
garlic
yeah it's very good
it tastes good yeah but pretty hot this
is my favorite there we go it's my
favorite
yeah
it's super spicy though that I was just
about to say yes but it's spicy
smooth anymore yeah I was just about to
say I was like that's when I've been
that way I was like whoa
this one's pretty hot and then when
you're like this is my favorite one I
was like really
but
oh my God this is smart
this is really bad
you strike me as a Sentimental person of
all the instruments that you own is
there one that stands out for the
backstory or its history
that I have there's this uh Peruvian
instrument that
I love that these are like a box it's
getting harder to talk I know yeah
that's the show no it's getting hard to
dark my tongue feels like it's like
okay a box
um
and it's very beautiful how it sounds
and I remember I used to play this
instrument
um in my in San Esteban where I come
from this little town
and
when I go to my mom's house and I see
that it always melts
this is so bad I know I know but you got
it he's getting worse
but it'll get better
and then we'll move on to the next wing
and it'll get worse again but this is
bad this I know I know I got you I got
you I gotcha
what does that mean
in the beginning I was like oh this
tastes sweet or something yeah that's
what I got when I smelled it I was like
this is one of the better smelling hot
sauces I've ever caught a whiff of
I like better than me
yeah this one really don't say they [__]
me up uh [__] me up that just works
that just works yeah this one I regret
that they came here
if I had a dollar for every time I heard
that really yeah people say that no I'd
have like 60 bucks
[Music]
what was important to you when working
with designer Dion Lee for the outfits
for your latest tour you know I imagine
that it was probably challenging to come
up with something that had like the
motorcycle aesthetic but that you could
also move around in and Dancing Yeah it
actually is always a challenge
every time trying to figure out clothes
for uh for a performance
and I wish that it was much easier
because he's
um usually a disaster
usually you know like you you have to
deal with shoes that maybe
I don't know you cannot do a spin with
it or I don't know like maybe um you're
showing a book I don't know it seems
like that can happen right these things
can happen so yeah you have to figure it
out and it's always a process and
everything but yeah I feel very grateful
that all the people that helped me
through all these years
to be on stage and not being naked
my lips hurt but it's okay
It Feels Like Somebody Come okay
I just got into a fight and somebody
punched me here
this one's [__] up it's me being
honest okay okay here we are okay
okay
[Music]
it's bad yeah
it's so bad I know and it just doesn't
stop I know I know
I know
but what you're doing today it was very
brave it's very brave
never eating hot sauce before and then
coming in here and eating maybe the
hottest hot sauce in the world
[__] I know I know
[Music]
it's painful yeah no uncomfortable I get
it I get it 100 I understand I relate
this is what inconvenient yes it's so
bad right thank you so much
ah
and then just be careful around the eyes
be careful around the eyes I'm right
with you I'm right with you
When J Balvin was on the show he taught
me how to say Picante Hasta la chimba
it's exact Spanish slang that you can
teach me to say that a dish is just like
spicy as hell
those meal
S I don't know how to describe this
um
[Music]
yeah that's how that that's how I would
say it yeah
I'm sweating I know I know I'm sweating
it's the hot ones glow that happens at
this time it's already glowing I was my
glow as perfect on points yeah yeah yeah
it's never looked better it's never
looked better
and just in time because as we move on
in the lineup we're going to be joined
by a very special guest oh my God yes
I need help
I got you what is this ice cream no
that's great thank you
he's at the end of the ambulance
[__] planet all right come in with
the ice cream
long time Partners in life First Time
Collaborators on the music side of
things so this one is the watermelon
ghost in the nine spot
you feel it
I never sweat eating you're right yeah
this is very strange I got fever yeah
okay
[Music]
right it's all good I think after the
last one
laughs
this is my job it makes me laugh
there you go I'm ready he's here for the
assist I'm here ready what a guy what a
guy
oh my God
what you need more Wheels I think he's
so bad that it makes me laugh like
I'm like oh my God it's making me great
love it is crazy oh my God
absolutely
I never seen you like this before
maybe four years together I swear man
you've been four years together no I
know I never been through this
well it's great you know like after all
these years and all the different
experiences you can still learn things
about each other you know exactly they
will never have this at home
the Apollo I like the name
okay you ready
yeah
that's a lot that's good that is perfect
that was a perfect pour that was a
perfect
poorly all right I'm ready
[Music]
he's got the ice cream
standing by
e I'll see
I know but the good news is
it's all over yeah right through it not
a spicy person today became one and to
close out the interview today we're
gonna dust off an old hot ones classic
right all right this is the bucket of
BFF questions yeah all right so what we
want you to do is each each in there
what a question and when you peel off
the question you ask the other person
okay okay the bomb
all right what's the question okay okay
what's your favorite song of mine
to watch me perform live
[Music]
what didn't I really like
I really like it
yeah all right that's good all right
Rosalia okay
okay let's go
[Music]
watch something new
you learn about me creating
and releasing music together for the
first time
like she likes like when she likes
minimal stuff so I'm more like kind of
like like more stuff in the production
yeah so you're more Baroque yeah and
then she's more simple more like clean
and minimal for me it's kind of cool too
you know just like I so I learned it's
different approach I tried to steal your
sauce sometimes
you know just do it my own way but like
she's inspired like she inspired me a
lot in music and in my personal lives
too so thank you so much you too you
can't steal her sauce today because look
at the way she took on the wings of
death Live to Tell the tale not a hot
sauce woman she walked in but definitely
a hot sauce woman now and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
eating uh Salsas Del Inferno and how it
was it was a disaster
and I think I never had a bad experience
eating till this day
I always love eating but not today not
today no sure not today
but yeah I can't wait to hit the stage
again because I'm touring right now in
Festival so so get those tickets
[Music]
I think it was exactly how I thought
yeah how I said like I was like it's
probably gonna be hard to handle at some
point but it's possible like it's like
human as a human I can do it you know
this is the spiciest meal you've ever
eaten in your life 100 wow 100 never in
my life I I had this and never again no
I'm not doing it I'm not doing it
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and I have an important announcement to
all the mini spice Lords out there and
those of us who like to just dabble on
the fringes of spiced them say hello to
our newest flavor from hot ones Jr it's
the red the red takes things up a notch
with ghost pepper and red carrot it
brings a warming Zing to all of your
favorite foods try it on gooey mac and
cheese this winter and thank me later to
get your hands on the hot ones junior
family of sauces visit heatness.com
that's heatness.com heatness.com red
light yellow light green light go now